it's funny you say this because when i  was 18 i actually did go to europe i  lived there for three months and it was  some of the most fun i've ever had i was  in germany and in the summer they have  these like outdoor parties there it  doesn't matter how old you are the whole  town comes remember like everyone would  party until the sun came up like when  the sun came up you went home funny  thing is this was on the 4th of july me  and my friend went to one of these  festivals in all american gear we were  the only ones there in american gear we  basically went around saying like i have  no friends so i made one literally made  one we called him paul honestly if you  get the opportunity i recommend studying  abroad because it is so so fun